voilà c'est maintenant au semis d'or la
chroniqueuse TPMP de l'année les femmes
c'est moi qui a l'honneur les nominés
sont
dans la catégorie Award de la
chroniqueuse TPMP de l'année les nommés
sont Daniel Moreau qui ne perd jamais
une occasion pour draguer même le
chauffeur de Guillaume Genton
Hama pendant tout le voyage
capot ou quoi
Géraldine maillet pour nous avoir offert
la séquence la plus haute de l'année
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Béatrice Rosen aussi talentueuse pour
ses interventions que pour ses pas de
danse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous trois
[Musique]
ça tombe bien aller à l'honneur ce soir
sur C8 on va revoir Delphine et Spieser
qui a lâché totalement
regardez
oui à vous trois choses que tu cries
pendant le sexe
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
si José je dirais ça ça sent le vécu
alors oui
[Rires]
non non cette vidéo a fait beaucoup de
vues aussi après sur internet mais ce
jeu est très marrant parce que quand on
nous force à dire des mots très très
vite ben
en fait
voilà peut-être que c'est ça oui Bernard
Montiel pour vous la chroniqueuse de
l'année alors moi Delphine évidemment on
est toujours très séduit en revanche je
veux dire que la scène dans l'eau dans
la piscine entre Géraldine maillet et
Béatrice c'est quand même magnifique
vous voulez la revoir oui
mais non c'est rien passé d'autre allez
au revoir
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il faut rappeler il faut rappeler qu'il
fallait en fait refaire la scène de
la piscine du loft 1 qui avait tant fait
parlé mais il n'avait pas fait que sur
les pelles à l'époque la meilleure
chroniqueuse de l'année pour moi oui
ah Daniel
donc le côté sexy Daniel Moreau
le problème euh les sexy Daniel allez
oui bah oui ça dépend ça façon
vous moi j'en ai pas particulièrement je
crois que les 5 c'est bien de mettre les
femmes à l'avant de TPMP voilà c'est je
trouve les 5 vraiment super donc
vraiment
si j'avais une préférée je vous l'aurais
dit c'est bien de de voir les femmes en
avant voilà par exemple dis-moi tu
pourrais dire bah c'est pour ça vous
n'êtes pas donc les cinq qui sont là
on va revoir Daniel qui s'est révélé
cette année
désespérément un homme et si on voulait
être plus précis elle cherche
désespérément une quéquette
peu importe le flacon pourvu qu'on en
est l'ivresse et dans son cas c'est très
important
et encore elle l'a pas vu allongé Reda
sache-le en amour il n'y a pas de geste
barrière
et aujourd'hui l'amour
frappé à ton levier de vitesse il a
quand même pris mon genou pour son frein
à main pendant tout le voyage
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais voir ce qu'il y a sous le
capot ou quoi
j'espère que elle va trouver chaussure à
son pied à Royan cet été révélation
cette année et on embrasse bien sûr
Daniel Moreau un excellent chroniqueuse
Guillaume j'entends pour vous Daniel
Moreau elle a un petit boule qui me
laisse pas indifférent
on va passer à la chroniqueuse pas ouf
de l'année alors ce sont les mêmes
aminés
à 21h15 sur C8 non
plus c'est très drôle ce qu'elle a fait
et en plus c'est du vécu donc elle coche
toutes les cases